for a lot of people this is very very
sensitive you did gave a voice note of
Kate speaking
you don't have to like the guy but at
the end of the day when you got two
people put on a list as now being the
victims but then they're coming out yeah
those two women are coming out and say
hold on why'd you put us on the list
we're not supposed to be on that list we
didn't tell you to put us on the list
we're not victims
I don't know what's happening right like
what really happened and why is why is
Romania going after him are they being
pressured by someone else to do this
should be covering is what happens if
they're an interesting place that should
be the story on the news please cover
that story there's no victims
those two women who've come out and said
that the police are made us into victims
but we're not victims
politicians ask the judges you're
getting closer to the truth strong
impactful moment where he walks in with
the Quran
this is
the beach
and I was explaining how much respect I
have for the faith
my next guest
PhD candidate researcher author blogger
teacher and he is currently taken on the
role of an independent investigative
reporter as he's been reporting on the
Andrew Tate situation and has been
quoted as a source for many different
Outlets
that have sourced his work so let's find
out more and why he's taken on this role
and what he has uncovered thank you for
having me on my mother is a major major
fan of y'all so it's an honor to be here
and be your guest martial law nice to
have you on Suleiman
thank you thank you for having me so
you've taken on this role as an
independent uh reporter pretty much uh
investigating this case is this
something you do for a living it's not
and and it was never my intention to do
so and the reasoning for um doing it was
actually quite simple what happened was
the Taylor Brothers had been arrested
and you saw an almost trial uh by media
and social media and social media was
having a large impact and we're going to
Greater detail in that once if you if
you raise a letter but social media was
having a big impact and social media is
having a big impact on societal views on
what was happening as well as the the
Romanian Judiciary and so after a few
days I mean I did not engage I don't
know Andrew and neither do I
um
uh neither have I have spoken to him but
when I saw the vilification I thought
you know it's our duty as Muslims to
look at the evidence and look at the
information and so that's all I did my
plan was never to you know start
supporting him or trying to provide
evidence to you know support his
position but as I delved into the
evidence I found it to be quite
different to what was being portrayed
hence and I just felt like because
nobody was supporting him in terms of
from a academic investigative point of
view I thought it was my uh religious
imperative as well as my moral
imperative to try and analyze the
content and try and see what the
situation is
so are you saying you weren't like a
fanboy on the side and now you were just
blindly jumping into this you know at
whatever cost you know to try to defend
him you are objectively coming into this
as sure and I mean I the only my only
knowledge of Andrew was
um twice so once I went to visit my
brother-in-law's house and he had him on
and he was on a debate
with some Twitter stream and I said oh
he's won that a bit and then I walked
out I never thought about it again and
then some students in my school in
school I spoke to them and they told me
they were telling me what's the most
like popularized things because I think
it's always important as Educators as
islamist scholar as a teacher to know
what's happening with the youth and so
they told me all the two famous people
are Andrew Tate because he's a
misogynist and the other one was I sure
speed who was famous for apparently
barking so I then analyzed that with
them they told me some of his comments
and then I tried to explain it from a
from a
from a from a logical point of view the
other side of the argument and then more
recently because a certain
um
people on Twitter were talking about him
I've looked into him just before he
actually became arrested maybe about
four weeks before looking into just
basic videos and what the context was
but then other than that that's it I've
never like had any kind of affiliation
it was merely because when I saw him
arrested I thought you know what this
seems a bit dubious and hence that was
my thought but just not putting a
thought out there but after that it was
just solely independently analyzing if
the information come out that he was
guilty
I would not be supporting him
that's clear I mean that's obviously if
you if you felt at all that he was
guilty you would not be supporting him
you you would not uh be doing what you
were doing huh 100 and not so supporting
him also wasn't just that he's a Muslim
he's a Muslim brother and we love him
but at the same time it doesn't matter
if he's Muslim or Christian you know our
guidance is the Quran and the Sunnah and
and the statements of the scholars and
the Quran is very clear
um you know in variety of places but for
example in Surah Nissa and where it
states that one should be one we
are the custodians of Justice
our moral imperative to be to do justice
even if it's against yourself or your
own family so this is just an imperative
for all Muslims it's not about whether
you liked her or disliked her you agree
with them how you don't agree with him
just be just look at the information
fairly when someone provides me with
information and it looks problematic I
will say it's problematic a good example
of this is and
before this case someone did say oh look
here's a video of Andrew Ted
and he was saying in that video are Isis
at the Real Islam when I watched the
video I said yeah that's that's just
silly right but then what happened was I
think a week before he was arrested he
went on the PS Morgan show and he said
look that was my view when I was an
atheist
I had the incorrect View and I will
apologize for this view that I had 10
years ago when I was an atheist and
that's no longer since I've converted
Islam my view so that's just an example
of being objective if you say something
which is ridiculous we will say it and
if there's something that he said which
is good we will say it it's just it's
very simple this has no nothing to do
with Duty or or some kind of um you know
affiliation just because he's out a
Muslim brother this is just about
looking at what's right and what's wrong
because if we live in a society
where we don't look at the evidence and
we don't look at the data and we don't
look at the information and we base
everything on our emotions that is an
anarchistic society and it will lead and
we'll talk about this layer will lead to
much more worse things
so this seems like right up your Forte
so you hit your a PhD candidate and your
specialty is what research
so my actual spell specialty is a
theology it could be the Islamic law
thick as well as philosophy so that's
actually my specialty but in terms of
but
analyzing content or information I guess
it does come into that so what have you
uncovered thus far what are some of the
key points that kind of kicked it off
and you went further and further
yeah so firstly what happened was
there was a a number of large and and
why this is important is this because
when I looked at the judicial document
and we're going to go into that more
detail I presume later but when I looked
at the judicial document and the reason
for remand one of the reasons they gave
was about information that they'd
garnered from social media
so that told me or that made me realize
that actually what's happening in social
media as well as the people psyche
within social media is very important
because if that's been used to determine
to remind him for longer it means that
one needs to provide the other side of
the argument so there was a number of um
people in social media who were
producing content which were I guess I
guess anti-tier but trying to
demonstrate or say that he was guilty so
my first point of call was to look at
what they produced and analyze the
information and see whether it stood up
so as an example
um one piece of information one the
first thread we can I'll just give that
example so the first thread I saw it was
showing you know
um Andrew tear
um having relations with someone with
consent which based on our Islamic
Paradigm is not acceptable it's Haram
it's wrong that's something that you
can't def but again that's jahalia
that's what we say when someone comes
over to Islam they came from a day of
ignorance and we have many people like
that who like we have a past life you
come in you just you don't have the
guidance and you're living according to
your desires and that's like you know
the majority of human beings out there I
mean we've got so many examples
um as you mentioned it and for example
um
in the time of jahaliah they used to
have bets so a woman would be pregnant
and they'd have vets and say look is it
a boy or a girl and then it caught you
out while the woman was alive just to
see if they want to bet so that was the
level of
um
a level of um acting which was in bad
Badness before coming to Islam and then
as um became one of the best proponents
of Islam it was essentially a genius and
so that shows how someone can completely
change and become an important factor
within Islam I mean These Guys these
these uh these men who are the greatest
men of all time now these are people who
were burying their baby girls alive
100 I mean they were they tried to kill
the prophet Muhammad they did the most
just notoriously evil things but then
they changed
for sure and the Quran came to make that
change and so like 100 and so but just
that point because they brought it up so
that was before but even then when it
was before within that Western liberal
Paradigm that's considered acceptable
behavior and that's the Paradigm he was
living in and that was the Paradigm of
his belief system
within that Paradigm which is linked to
the law as well what he was doing was
not illegal and it wasn't even
considered bad according to their
paradigm
so I just highlighted that and showed
that look the woman came out she
actually said that look I consented so
that was one example the second example
was this information that had been
spread about
um about him and then after that what I
did was that was the first thread
and the second thread was I looked at
the die-cut reports so the die-cut
report is basically when the police
um arrested
um Andrew tier in April as well as in uh
29th of December
the produced a die-cut rapport for the
public to read and in that report
there was nothing about the U.S woman
being present when the house was raided
but across social media that was one of
the main arguments that were making that
the woman was kidnapped and it was the
police who'd come in and saved her but
the report didn't state that so again I
had to demonstrate that that was
inaccurate and refute it so that was
another example of of that of going
through the information because say that
say that last part again yeah so
basically they argued that she'd been
kidnapped and she was being held without
her will and a huge and and then what
and they said it without evidence but
then what they did was first of all they
provided a 16 second YouTube clip of the
woman in the house walking towards the
exit
so what I did was I went through the
die-cut report and showed that actually
when dicot went in they mentioned they
gave no mention about the woman being
present during the raid
the second thing is that the YouTube
clip that they'd be presented had been
snipped from a longer three minute and
20 second video
which was available on YouTube for four
months
and and if you actually produce the
whole video it shows the woman was going
in going out going getting some pizzas
you know coming back and so it presents
a totally different picture on why
that's a problem is it just shows the
nefarious nature of
um what was happening in terms of taking
Snippets and that that's been a
significant problem through all of this
has been Snippets is is this the woman
that you're talking about who had the
conversation with her boyfriend and then
she told her boyfriend that she was
being held against her will is that the
one and then that is and then the police
then the police came and pretty much she
went out and got some pizza came back
and is that the same one that was uh
later on came there was an allegation of
of a woman being graped I'll you know
what I'm talking I'll just replace the
word and then there's video you can't
even watch this I mean but it's like of
them twerking and they're back partying
again is that the same one it is the
same woman and um the woman isn't that
specific woman hasn't accused him
um it's actually a moldovan woman so
there's two women currently that we have
information on which is the U.S woman
yeah as you said she came so just think
about this like a woman travels from the
United States on her own and goes all
the way to Romania to meet a man a man
who who is very
um on his Instagram and his social media
he's them because it was Tristan
undertale
um who demonstrates a very uh a specific
type of Lifestyle with you know partying
and women and these type of luxurious
lifestyle and yet she was aware of that
and still traveled to another country
so that's a pro so this woman makes that
decision she goes there and then as you
said
um those things happen
so then the the the one that you're
talking about there's there are two
distinct you mentioned moldovia this
yeah so this is not the same one then no
so what basically you've got an
accusation which is allegedly the Six
Women yeah accused
um the tits of human trafficking
or as you said um
um grip the the problem is that the
moldovan woman has made the accusation
in terms of the relations yeah and the
other five women have made Acquisitions
in terms of human trafficking now do you
know now you said six but hasn't uh you
also post about there was two that
actually were put on this list that said
we're not victims so it kind of gets
right that's right that was going to
come to that yeah so you basically got
and those two women who've come out and
said that the police are made those into
victims but we're not victims I mean you
can just you can like not like the guy
and you can just you know but I mean you
you got to be fair I mean come on like
uh well this is a huge problem I think
you've just you just pointed on to a
very important point because and and the
Quran calls us like you quoted earlier
to be just you know even if it would be
against yourselves so I mean this is
just obvious stuff you don't have to
like the guy but at the end of the day
when you got two people put on a list as
now being the victims but then they're
coming out yeah those two women are
coming out and say hold on why'd you put
us on the list we're not supposed to be
on that list we didn't tell you to put
us on the list we're not victims we're
actually and they're stalking positive
this is like what's going on here but
that should scare us and I'll explain
why because we're living in a society
Society where they've gone completely
opposite so just as we are we critically
analyze our own tradition for example
sometimes within Islam unfortunately men
used to use marriage as um a form of
control of women and only men and that's
a weakness
but similarly we've gone on the other
way now and and in more ways than one
and I'll explain it because basically
what's happened here is what this sin is
these two women who've come out and said
guess what
we've never been victims of human
trafficking he actually treats us like
family what they're saying is guess what
don't believe the guy and don't believe
them women because they've got Stockholm
Syndrome so just imagine what kind of
society that is I can actually take you
out if I want and say guess what you've
had incorrect relations with somebody
and took advantage of them and you said
no I never did it and then the woman
says no you didn't do it and Abby and
then I can say no no no she's got
Stockholm Syndrome
and then you can go to jail and
Stockholm syndrome for the people that
don't know what does that mean is that
you know when you've been taken
advantage of and you've been under the
control of a person you start developing
feelings for the person and you do
whatever the person says so even if that
person has kidnapped you in your mind
you say you've convinced yourself no no
he hasn't and so you'll stick up for
that person even though he's taken
advantage of you
that's what Stockholm syndrome is can
that be flipped around the other way as
far as because we live in a time of like
you know
um that everything has to be fair across
the board everybody's right so can that
be flipped and it said that now the man
is the man was whooped and he was you
know the the woman had made him do these
things like you know no no we don't live
in that Society you see so we live in a
unfortunately we live in a feminist
society which has a significant
man hatred and that's the society we
live in just look at just look at our
society look at um within the Western
marriage so for example just marriage in
the West
marriage in the west is basically a one
especially in the UK because I I don't
know you American laws much in the UK
marriage is a one-way contract for a man
to promise that he's going to be
monogamous but it's not the other way
around and let me explain why because if
the man
cheats she gets 50 of what he gets of
everything right but on the other hand
if the woman cheats
the man has to make a decision now
I'm gonna let her treat
or I'm gonna say no you can't cheat and
I'm gonna lose 50 of everything
wow so essentially it's a one-way
monogamous contract and only a woman can
choose so this is so we're not living in
a fair Society anymore and that's what
we should be free for love because these
things that we're seeing and I'm gonna
come on to another example of that these
things that we are saying
are actually man hatred and it's not
just man hatred in terms of men you can
go even more deeper if you look at lgbtq
the trans Community even within that if
you look at it they'll always attack
trans women by biological men but
they'll never TR attack trans men you'll
never see you'll never see Dave
Chappelle or anyone from the left or
anyone from the right rarely I see it
where they'll attack a woman who's who's
a trans man who's become
who is a biological woman who's changed
but the other way around it happens a
lot so that's the app so someone like JK
Rowling can get away who's a feminist
with attacking someone a trans man but
not and she would never think about
attacking a trans woman so the death of
man hatred in feminism is actually very
deep
hmm
so let's continue on with some of these
points and I know for a lot of people
this is very very sensitive and I know
just touching on this you know is
something that now people are like why
are you even you know bringing this up
but this this can set a precedence for
tomorrow let's just you know make an
extreme example let's say this happens
to one of your favorite uh public
speakers uh and somebody who has a great
track record and now they want to go
ahead and try to persuade you that he's
done you know this X Y and Z and you're
not looking at the evidence and then
you're it's like almost like a magic you
know the the media machine that's out
there so if you don't end up you know
looking at the evidence like you said
having a stand for justice and whatnot
and we're trying to make a clear line
because obviously it's very clear you
know these things from jahalia that a
person does these things are totally
prohibited in Islam these are things
that you know we don't stand for and
we're the most adamant against these
things
webcam porn all these things I just
totally but this is this is not what
we're talking about we're talking about
looking at the facts looking at the
evidence and when you're holding
somebody hostage now no evidence you
know and then you have uh witness
tampering you have uh that you're not
supposed to be doing but you're actually
bringing on Witnesses right that are not
supposed that are not victims and now
they're coming out I mean and then
you're still you know holding on to the
person and whatnot I mean you know
people who don't even like the guy are
coming out and saying hold on this is
fishy this don't make sense this is so
you've uncovered some of these things so
let's continue on with uh what you were
you were bringing to light of course I
will do and just to add to your point in
any society whenever you want to create
a decoronian measure you always Target
somebody that
that you will get support about
targeting that person so as an example
when they wanted to in Twitter ban
uh ban certain things that went for
Donald Trump for example now Elon Musk
wants to ban certain people he's went
for Kanye so there's always a scenario
where they'll always ban someone where
everyone's like yeah that guy's a bad
guy
oh we don't like that person or we
disagree with his lifestyle okay we're
not going to say nothing about the
reason for the Banning but then that
reason is then deployed on society and
then you have no way of speaking out and
so that's why it's always important to
speak out in these scenarios because
once they confirm them once they vote
for those you don't like they will
deploy them same reasoning for the
people you do like
in terms of then what I uncovered was
in the next thread then what happened
was within that short period of time
there was a report from Romania and
allegedly Andrew had been messaging some
16 year old girls of Romanian officials
so again I looked into that and what we
found was a lot of the information that
was being presented looked very very
weak as an example first of all the
women the girls they claimed that
um Andrew had been had millions of
followers but at that time as far as
remember 2019 he only had it in the
hundreds of thousands the second problem
was that the images that they provided
didn't marry up so they said it was
Instagram but the in the what the images
they provided didn't look like it was
from Instagram and they have even been
doctored
and then more concerning than that these
women and this should be the biggest
concern these women or girls
oh sorry the the third point is
they
claimed that they knew about the
intricate intricacies of the webcam
business but then they'd never been part
of it and then the last point which is
the most concerning is and this is
concerning for me as well is these girls
were connected to Romanian officials so
uh for example one of them was the
daughter of uh kuzman gusa and Guzman
guza is a
right wing
according to my own um reading so I
couldn't be misreading him because you
are using Google Translate in this
aspect but he looks very conservative
and quite right-wing and why that is
important is this sometimes people like
Andrew K don't realize he is
mixed race and he is a Muslim and what
happens is you don't realize the level
of
um what impact that can have on Eastern
Europe because Eastern Europe
not completely but does have a tendency
to have islamophobic ideas as well as
racism this is well known within Eastern
Europe and not completely obviously not
I'm not putting everybody in that
bracket but this happens so it's very
very possible
that when his conversion to Islam
happened they probably thought you know
what we're going to allow you
even though you're mixed race but you
know what we're gonna allow it but now
you become Muslim that's just taking the
bar too far now you're basically acting
like this or ruining your business in
our country uh whatever it may be
because remember
people who are close to him have said
that he stopped the webcam business
um before he joined Islam or quite very
soon very very close to when he joined
Islam
is this is a correct statement this is
from like 10 years ago plus
um so this is what's confusing so
basically his the report the die-cut
reports is the investigations from 2021
afterwards so we have to look at the
evidence and I have looked at the
evidence so we're going to go into that
in terms of specific allegations but
this and it's after 2021 in terms of the
webcam business it was before that but
they've arrested him basically three
weeks after he's joined Islam and
remember he was in Dubai for most of
that so it's not been long since he
joined Islam that he converted to Islam
that he's gone back to Romania and then
this has happened and so and so when
reports coming out from the Judiciary
one is to always think that there's
going to be some kind of from
politicians one needs to always think
that there's maybe some kind of ulterior
motive and just to give you an example
of that you know when he was raided you
had the Judiciary the prosecutors and
journalists all involved because the
journalists were there they were ready
with their you know 4D cameras or
whatever the latest cameras are they
were ready for the raid yeah and they
did the red so they were all working
together similarly there's been certain
leaks that have been coming out from the
prosecutor to that press again showing
that there is some kind of relationship
between them that they present in these
ID ideas in this manner so that's a
point of concern
um now my thoughts about that is when I
looked at the things that have been
leaked they've been so weak that if
that's the strongest evidence they got
there's no case if that's the weakest
then let's see let's look at the
evidence and my view is this we are not
supporting Ted because he is Andrew Ted
if some unequivocal evidence comes the
show his is guilty I will definitely say
look that evidence is unequivocal
there's nothing we could say about it
but up to now does not happen so that's
in terms of the early part of it then
what happened was
uh then um so now I'll move on to the
more specifics of the actual allegations
so in terms of specific of the specifics
of the allegations you've got a scenario
where I went through the judicial
documents and you basically got a nine
page document that the judge released to
provide his reasoning you went through
you went through these judicial
documents yourself you went okay how do
you go through them if they're in
Romanian or if they're in different
language that's a very good question so
I basically
um Google translated them and then I got
them double checked by somebody who
could speak Romanian nice okay yeah I
think that's important
um to do because Google Translate is not
always perfect perfect yeah and now what
those documents say is this which is
points of concern this now I'm gonna
specifically I'm gonna first talk about
the allegations of great and then I'll
talk about the human trafficking
allegations so the first allegation
you've got a scenario where it's only
the moldovan woman
who claims this to be the case the SEC
the uh the U.S woman does not claim this
and we'll talk about her a bit more when
we talk about um the trafficking
accusations now
the moldovan woman has made this
accusation and the only evidence they
have is a witness statement the witness
statement was done sorry her witness
statement was done weeks later so as you
said you had these allegations you had
those videos of these women partying and
doing
um inappropriate um actions after the
fact after the fact I mean I want people
just don't lose your place but just just
picture that like you make an accusation
of something then you come back to the
accusers resident and you party there
and you twerk yourself there and you are
you know with your phone you know you're
taking uh uh Tick Tock videos what's
going on exactly it's just it's just
ridiculous and what you see in the video
videos is they've got their phones so if
you've got access to phone you can text
on Instagram you can text on Facebook
you can contact anybody so it kind of
defeats the whole I I mean there are
legitimate victims out there this is
like it seems like it takes the fuel the
energy people who are suffering who are
this is such a horrific crime this is
something that Islam is like so you know
hard on and you know it's just sad to
take you know you're taken away from the
real real victims out there while you're
over here partying you know you're
coming back to your accuser and you're
just having a blast you know what I mean
and putting it out there for the whole
world to see and then and then this now
you
this comes up I'm so glad you mentioned
that because that's an important point
to know
myself I've got family members who's
been a victim of domestic abuse I've
helped a woman who
um said that she'd been taken advantage
of by a religious scholar so we're not
saying don't believe any women but
similarly we're saying don't believe all
women because if you can't have both
and as you said anytime you go into one
of the extremes
no one's going to believe real victims
and similarly innocent people will go to
jail and that's what Islam stops and
hence why we have this idea of doing
things from the legalistic point of view
having Witnesses so going back to the
moldovan woman
tits
um
personal assistant as well as
um someone who's involved in her company
went out went on Romanian National TV
and she said that when the alleged
incident happened there was actually two
other women present at the same time
and those women are saying it didn't
happen so now you got two more witnesses
who are there when the situation was
supposed to have happened that they are
um reporting that they're making
accusations for and these two witness
saying no it's not true exactly right
because they would have been accomplices
then exactly okay and then so that
you've got that incident and then after
that when you look at the judicial
documents what the judge is saying is
guess what we've got the witness
statement of the woman and what the
women did well woman the women did was
the two of them even though one's only
accusing they went to a
psychologist and mid rapport
but it wasn't a approved one even though
it is an expert psychologist
so they're the only two pieces of
evidence they've got and what the judges
said is that's enough evidence to remind
them for 28 days
sorry 30 days that's enough evidence to
remind them for 30 days but it's not
enough evidence to prosecute or convict
so therefore Mr prosecutor you need to
provide a new evidence of additional
evidence so that we can actually
prosecute the test on this allegation in
my mind so this is now just my opinion
in my mind I can't see what evidence
they could get that could prove that
allegation even because about nine
months to find this evidence these when
when you accuse someone of something
like that the evidence is going to be
more closer to the time rather than
after the time if it's taking you nine
months to find this evidence I find it
hard to believe that they will find this
evidence later
further further just in in this specific
case
and just to show you that there's
something strange going on between the
Judiciary and the prosecutor they only
gave and the Tate's team the legal files
45 minutes before they were gonna take
him to court to decide about reminding
him
and so this is the problem we have this
a huge in terms of that specific case
the evidence is weak the women have
disappeared
so you don't know have they gone to the
US if they have that seems suspicious
where have they gone no one knows and
the evidence specifically for that is
very very weak
and now this and I'll go on to the human
trafficking in a bit but also what's
been proliferating throughout um
social media as well as the normal media
media is
there's a company called Vice
and that company has released two
articles as well as a TV documentary hit
piece
and they were definitely geared to be
hit pieces because you can see from the
direction that there was no balance
there was no positives in terms of the
way things happen to during because what
happened was the vice reporter went to
um
Andrew tear and Tristan Ted's house and
spent three days there where they didn't
miss mixed martial arts and he presented
that as something which was very bad
like men being violent doing martial
arts and never looked at the positives
and I'm aware that you're involved in
martial arts and I don't think would you
you wouldn't agree that it's some
violent aggressive support and there's
no benefits to it would it would you
um
exactly there's going to be a huge
amount of there's a huge huge benefits
yeah no all martial arts yeah and
absolutely yeah a huge amount of
benefits whether it's physical benefits
mental benefits physical yes
there's a huge amount of benefits and he
didn't he didn't speak about any of that
but specifically talking about the vice
hit pieces there was an allegation
against the Tate in 2015 this is the
first allegation
and there was two women who accused him
and what happened was those two women
went to the police and they accused him
now in that time in the United Kingdom
we used there used to be a rule that
whenever someone accused someone you
would take their phones
both the accuser and the accused so they
took the women's phone they looked
through it and what they found on those
phones were that the women were speaking
to each other and colluding with each
other about the accusation you can look
this up this is something that's out
there yeah yeah yeah
it's actually on vice's piece but they
don't highlight it how come why isn't
mainstream media showing that part well
this is the problem because everything's
about the way you um present it yeah and
so when for example there was a vice
reporter Sophie who presented this and
she made it look like the reason it was
dropped was because the CPS made
mistakes and the police delayed but in
reality that's not what happened the
police did make delays which was
unacceptable this they took four years
to investigate that is not gonna that is
unacceptable
but the police's delays actually affect
both parties if you're a victim imagine
waiting four years it can be
heartbreaking but at the same time if
you're innocent waiting four years for
your name to be exonerated is very very
stressful
so that with the police but once the
information went to the CPS because the
CPS in the United Kingdom what they do
is they look at the information and they
say you know what is this strong enough
that we can prosecute if it's not if the
evidence is strong enough not strong
enough that they drop the case and they
don't take it forward
so the CPS when they were deciding the
Merit of it said that look these two
women are colluding they're sending each
of the voice notes and then various
other reasons for it and then they
dropped the case and so that was the
reason for that piece but they didn't
highlight that and they presented it in
this way that actually it was dropped
because of the CPS which is hugely
problematic you should always provide
things which are balanced but then the
second advice hit piece was even worse
in terms of agenda driven you had a
woman from 2013
who accused uh Andrew te and what they
did was
very nefariously again the police had
both evidences but Vice never demons
presented it you did give a voice note
of care speaking
muhammadan rasulullah
wow mashallah I feel like a new man now
it's time to marry a Somali bad one in
an Islamic marriage and create Abby
Trump Jr to run my new Paris and Hill of
Empire
from now on please refer to me as Darwin
Mohammed in Trump
which sounds bad it's it is unacceptable
again I said in the Islamic in Islam
it's Haram but in the western Paradigm
this type of like pink type Behavior
they consider it acceptable so he was
speaking in in a vulgar manner
but we don't have the woman's voice so
imagine me cutting just half of it that
is very very nefarious because you
should always listen to both sides of a
conversation so that you can fully
understand what's happening and they did
the same thing with the messages so in
the message it says I want to you know
you I want to you know do something bad
to you but they don't put her messages
in the article and then it's only in the
documentary they flash it for one second
and luckily some people were astute
enough that they paused it and they saw
the message and in and then they put a
message on this social media which I
added to my article
where they said where she says
it can't be right if I consented
so it can't be great if unless like
she's saying this yes that's right so
this is the part that they conveniently
left out exactly
and so that's the horrendous nature of
the vice report in because they had an
agenda they went ahead with that agenda
and even with the video there's many
videos showing how they cut certain
things to make and make them look bad
but when people have put the full video
on it it's just totally different to the
scenario so that was basically so and so
the why isn't why I mentioned that even
though they're not relevant to the case
is because the biased nature of a report
but the biased niche of social media and
normal medium reporting and then what's
worse about that case sorry is
in 20 sorry they realized that guess
what you're gonna get they're going to
get backlash because what that woman in
2013 did was she continued relations
with Andrew te
for six months after the allegation
so I'm talking relations as well as
being still being her girlfriend
they knew this was a problem so they
tried to come by so how they come back
they was they got a feminist
researcher to say actually this is
normal behavior
so I looked into this feminist
researcher and she had wrote or
presented a conference paper on uh
Simone and
why that's important is if she is
somebody who considers who thinks of
Simone as in such a positive light well
Simone is the reason for second wave
feminism she is the one that calls
second with feminism but more than that
these are the type of people that
they're using as evidence
she was known that she wanted to
decriminalize pedophilia rules
and more worse than that she with uh we
used to basically seduce minus with
Jean-Paul Sartre and then have something
called the trio so you know like how you
heard about Giselle Max uh sorry Giselle
Maxwell and X team so they had that type
of behavior going on but with miners
and she is considered
uh The Authority or someone that this
woman looks up to so this is the
ideology of feminism or well it seems
like that because she's doing a
conference paper on it it may not be the
case but I'm just presenting to you in
terms of what they did to try and combat
the problem that they knew they had so
in terms of Vice the uh the information
is very weak
finally the last allocation is human
trafficking
now the problem with the human
trafficking is this
and again in Islam I want to be clear
weary against we're against the webcam
business we're against quality funds
we're against you know in even Instagram
what women are using projection uh
projecting themselves uh in order to
gain money or gain this type of uh we're
against all of it in our Paradigm this
is not allowed and this entire Paradigm
is a actually more it's the manipulation
of a man rather than a woman it's
actually men who have not got access to
women who are not married or have gotten
no way of um you know having relations
with women are giving away stupid
amounts of money just to have some kind
of interaction with a woman even if it's
something as measly as watching her
drink water so that's the level of
Western Society is gone and men are
definitely being
um are being used in this manner and
manipulated so definitely this is a
manipulation of men exploded in this
area yeah exploitation of men and it's
an exploitation of women
to a smaller extent because women are
actually making money whereas the men
are just giving away money
but coming back to that because I think
that's an important point to know
because people unfortunately when you
look at the case and analyze it they try
and pay you as being someone who
supports these ideas but we don't
now in terms of the specific case
you've got a scenario where you've got
six women two of the women
have said that we have been called
victims but we are not victims here's
family so if we take their word for it
that leaves only four women
two of the women are the U.S woman and
the moldovan woman the U.S woman
was not there long enough that there
could have even been a human trafficking
because there's not us there's no
evidence being presented and nor has any
statements come out from and she was
right yeah yeah but she's been presented
by for example Eliza and a few people
who are quite popular on on social media
who read her statement out publicly and
she's the one and she's the one that
went to get the dominant they got
Domino's Pizza over there or she went to
go right I mean I think it was Domino's
yeah it was some kind of pizza for sure
yeah and so that that's her so now the
question Becomes of the three women
which one so one of them is saying is
one of them is gives a different
accusation so we've only got two women
so my question to the other side has
been actually which I asked recently
which ones are actually accusing of
human trafficking who's accusing of it
what's the evidence and what's the
information
um they've provided nothing they don't
even know which women are accusing him
accusing him of it accusing them of it
and why they're accusing him that's an
important point to know now the second
point is now let's look at the judicial
documents so again the judicial
documents explain the level of evidence
that they've got in terms of human
trafficking and I am going to be writing
a thread on this this is the threat I'll
be releasing on Wednesday or Thursday so
but these are my initial thoughts
without detail analysis but I think it's
good enough to present uh on your Shore
so the judicial document said that guess
what there has been human trafficking
and that again the information they have
is based on witness statement
as well as wiretapping now the wiretap
in this air is on a social app so I'm
presuming that could be WhatsApp or
Instagram or something like that where
conversations are occurring so this is
the information we've got now like I
said what the judges said is the
information that they have on this
is only enough to remand but isn't
enough to prosecute again and isn't
enough to convict so now after nine
months of wiretap
and they've leaked certain things to the
press and like I said earlier if those
are the strongest piece of evidence
they've got they've got no case but
let's go with the worst case scenario
that is the weakest evidence they've got
we need to wait for what that
information is on the white tab but
currently what the judge is in is even
after I've seen that information
the evidence isn't strong enough that
that prosecute ought to convict who said
that now this is the the leader the
leading judge he said this that's right
in his nine page judicial document so
now what that means is
the prosecutor and the police and the
die-cut or whatever it may be while
they've got the tits in prison actually
looking for evidence so imagine putting
someone in prison
detaining them of their freedom and now
you're looking at evidence and remember
as Muslims we've experienced this and to
a greater extent it was in Go China
movie where people were sent to there
without a trial
without ever being given an opportunity
to defend themselves and we were against
it then and we're still against it
because everything should be based on
evidence and if the and the judge
explained
that the evidence is enough to remind
but you know what he's even said guess
what the evidence is enough to remind
but um I think it's still good to I but
my basis of deciding why I want to
remind is that Andrew Tay is a social
personality social media personality
he's well known if he goes out
it will make our Judicial System look
bad so for me
my interpretation of that is they're
afraid that when he comes out he'll
speak and he'll make them look worse so
they want to stop his speech as well the
second and so he's they said we want to
stop
that's one of the reasons and another
reason was they said that we looked at
social media and we looked at that
information on social media to make it
online to make a judgment now the
problem with this is this
that's horrendous because
I've seen it myself while I've been
looking into this case when people take
Clips out of context of course he looks
horrendous
but whenever you look at it in a longer
form or when he's given a detailed
explanation it doesn't look as bad let
me give you an example
so for example he says
um you know women are dumb they'll say
women are not as smart as men right so
me I'm an academic and I'm an Islamic
scholar so for me I can give the
evidence say look in Islam in the Quran
we have this idea of they've been two
female witnesses to mark one male
witness what's the reason for that well
we know in the 1970s and 80s there was a
significant amount was a research done
to demonstrate that showed that when
traumatic event occurred
women's recall was much worse than men's
that type of research is Haram now
according to Western is blasphemy
according to Western liberalism so that
research won't be happening outside
that's why we have to look at all the
research so now I can give my academic
example or chronic example and say guess
what you know
and women's recall is not as strong and
hence why we have this legislation in
Quran and it makes logical sense for it
and so on and so forth whereas Andrew
Tate will say in a more uh Amplified way
where younger people can understand say
look women are not smart when have they
ever learned something but so he'll say
in a more in a way that actually it
works with the youth but in reality when
you look at the basis or the foundation
of it there is some basis of foundation
behind it so that's just an example of
when you can take someone out of context
up in in that scenario but then another
scenario is when you clip him and you
throw only a few seconds or a minute and
not look at the longer form and if the
judge is using that which he said he is
as a way of deciding to remind him I
think that's hugely problematic as well
and the last thing that they said that
they uh that they used to remind him was
you know the two cases that I've
explained to you in detail the 2013 case
or the 2015 case in the United Kingdom
but that again is problematic because if
you're using that
and the United Kingdom have said
this is not strong enough
this was not strong enough we've looked
at the evidence we've not looked at
what's on we've not looked at what Vice
have said but we've actually looked at
the women's phones we've looked at the
fact that the woman was having relations
with him for six months later and we've
now decided that the evidence isn't
strong enough and we look at the text
messages back and forth and the evidence
isn't strong enough to prosecute why are
they then using that in the Romanian
case again that is hugely problematic
yeah I mean it doesn't make any sense I
mean this is something that was dropped
in another country this is like isn't
this out of your jurisdiction that's
another point so that's a secondary
point which is a second not secondary is
a second point which is as important
it's a different jurisdiction as well
why would you rely on something in the
United Kingdom you don't know what the
threshold is the United Kingdom would
never rely on Romania dropping a kiss
because they don't know what the
threshold is
wow there's a lot of uh
things here that are and you pointed out
also some political uh reasons that this
was used also for sure there's a lot of
things coming out about that so there's
political reasons as I've explained
where you can see that the politicians
involved in someone just released
another one and uh so there's twofold
there's another reason first of all nuts
in the release Romania
in their standings for human trafficking
is very low so the United States have
like a ranking system
and they've said that the Romanian
Romanians are very low down and they
want to try and improve that and they
want to get in the Shenzhen Zone as well
and what's the best way to do that is to
try and go after a world famous guy
and try and get him on these charges and
if you get him on these charges you I
mean you've got the most famous man on
the planet on these charges you then are
giving yourself a good standing to go up
in those human trafficking rankings as
well as your application to the Shenzhen
Zone that's the first aspect the second
aspect is that there's a lot of things
coming out which I've not read too much
into detail on now two months just sent
me it just it was literally just before
your show I retweeted it but I've not
looked into it in detail well again
politicians are
basically using this as a leverage to be
able to get elected in 2024 so there's a
huge amount of politics uh involved the
Judiciary involved the prosecute
involved I I know people don't like me
talking about this as much because
whenever I bring it up they always try
and change the conversation but I really
really believe it I'm not just saying it
to defend him in Eastern Europe in some
of these countries there is a
significant amount of islamophobia there
is huge yeah and there is a significant
amount of racism and so to ignore that
and think that this never happened
because this was a guy who made Romania
look good he was free advertisement for
them people used to think wow
we're concerned about the Petals of the
west where liberalist ideologies go in
and and and and so they thought you know
what what's the alternative and the
alternative was he was trying to present
Eastern Europe as a solution and uh
Romania as a solution obviously it's
demonstrated that he made an error he
did not realize that his how his his
um
his wrist but more so his religion was
going to be impact Romania and it
clearly has and you saw and I made a bit
of a like sarcastic tweet about this but
when you saw that
strong impactful moment where he walks
in with the Quran
that was huge for Muslims it was huge
for him but what that showed me is
his conviction about the Deen is so much
that he is willing in a very Orthodox
Christian country a country which will
have racist Tendencies and has Islamic
phobic tendencies
to show that and allow and risk being
prison imprisoned and risk that the
judge is going to have a negative mind
frame about you
that is just major I'll be honest if it
was me
I would not have done it because I would
have tactically thought you know what if
I do this
they're gonna get me they're going to
say I'm guilty and then people are going
to believe I'm guilty so let me prove my
innocence and then I'll and then I'll
show my strength and belief of the deal
or to risk that it takes a huge amount
of character strength and thought to say
that you know what convict me
but I'm not bothered because one might
ask me more is the religion and Allah
that for me was huge
wow we're almost out of time yeah if you
just think about it just paint that
scenario you're coming in and if anybody
knows the the history there I mean just
being a neighboring state down in Bosnia
former Yugoslavia and you know the
history there with I don't know if
you've heard of the the techniques and
all the the greatest genocide that
happened after World War II and and this
is uh religiously motivated um and
there's a deep hatred a lot of uh huge
islamophobia there and this is uh uh
something that if you look into
Romania's history and if you look at
there uh from from that point of view
you you have and now to walk in with all
of this hanging over your head to walk
in with the Quran well I can give you
some anecdotal stories that basically I
traveled to Bulgaria which was again in
the same type of scenario as Romania but
anyway I traveled to Bulgaria and it
used to be part of the USSR and what
they had to do was
the USSR at that time came to eradicate
Islam and so what they did was they used
to hide the Islamic books the Islamic
classical books as well as the qurans
under underground so that they weren't
destroyed and then so many years later
now they showed me a lab and said look
these are the books that we buried
and now we've taken them out and we've
put them in the library so just to
assume that that kind of psychology is
completely died out is is not right to
be naive
so all of these factors need to be
considered so I will just say as my
final thoughts because as you said that
you're um we're about to close my final
thought of this it's very simple we are
not supporting Andrew tear and even my
support of him I wouldn't consider your
support we are looking at the
information
on its mirror if and the Mary is showing
that Andrew take based on the evidence
that we have right now is innocent
and based on looking at everything
because what people are doing is looking
at one information cutting out and
taking a giant leap but just looking at
the evidence on the face of it is our
moral and religious duty to speak the
truth
and I can tell you now there's no
benefits to volunteer zero I've not
received any benefit at all it's
actually the other way around I've been
canceled I've been kind my article was
taken down and my University post was
removed so I've been considerably your
article was taken down from where so I
had I I wrote an article
about
um about um Greta and Andrew Taylor and
the race issue
about it and then a leading black uh
newspaper approached me and said oh your
threat is so nice can you convert into
an article I said yeah sure I sent it to
them he saw it and he said your
article's brilliant didn't ask me for
any corrections put it up and then once
they got went public
and they saw my support of Ted they
removed my article
second thing was I was meant to teach a
module uh on Islam and Christian ethics
for undergraduates in University again
because they made complaints about
my posts about Tate
they said they investigating they
investigating it by the time they've
investigated and I'm able to respond
I won't be able to teach the module so
and so that's I've not received any
benefits just cancellation so there's no
benefit from supporting to it but the
only reason I'm doing it is because of
my religious and moral duty it's just
the right thing to do and if evidence
does come out
that and it's unequivocal because not
these kind of fake evidences that have
been seen now well I wouldn't call them
evidences but if unequivocal evidence
comes of course I will say I look that
evidence is strong he should be
convicted and that'll be the end of it
but up to now there's nothing and so as
Muslims
I will advise the Muslim Community
because I would say most of the Muslim
Community has been spoiling and some
have waited and then supported him but
there is a an element who are very vocal
against him and I'd say as a Muslim it's
your duty to look at the evidence and
it's your duty to look at the
information and make a decision and also
my last point about that is this
in Islam he's only converted to Islam
for a couple of months from our
understanding of Islam he's a child he's
learning even if he has got activities
that he was doing in the past
we have to judge him or we have to look
at the activity he did after that
furthermore there may be certain
activities that he'll be doing pre-islam
and he what and
what his friends have told me who are
Muslim for example such as Tam Khan that
he is making moves to separate himself
from that but we know when you've got
major businesses that are not Allah
it's not as easy as shutting them down
in a day but as long as you're putting
the points in place I'm taking the steps
in the measuring in place to stop them
that is good that is good at this point
and once enough time has passed and you
stop them then we can then people can
say bad things about him but right now
to basically
go after him and attack him based on his
Islam I believe is unacceptable and the
second thing is to go after him about
the charges which are very weak I
implore anybody that whenever you put
evidence out there research even me
whenever I see a piece of evidence like
I said now everybody now that
everybody's seen all the threads that
I've read I guess a huge amount of
information it's made things easier to
research actually because you get
centered but whenever I see a piece of
information I always ask where did this
come from where's the long form of this
and what is and and you know where and
is it legitimate and only when I get
that information do I ever post it as an
example there's a Romanian lawyer who
posted and said that you know the law in
Romania is that the test team should
have received the evidence 10 within 10
days so on the 29th of December 10
working days after that he should have
received you know the case File
it's now been well over that and they've
not received a case File but despite
that I didn't take that as evidence I've
now messaged him and said what is the
evidence that this 10-day rule exists
now if I was the other side they would
have posted a stray away but that's why
I'm saying I'm asking everybody please
look at the evidence properly look at
the data properly look at the
information properly verify it
understand that when you're presenting
an argument how are you presenting that
argument and when you're using certain
words why are you using those words as
an example some people are using the
word pimp and I have to write a long
thread to refute how he's not a pimp and
to provide evidence and provide
literature to prove that why he's not so
whenever you use terms and whenever you
make statements please please look at
the evidence that's our duties as
Muslims duties as human beings
uh it just came to my my mind when you
were talking about the we touched upon
the history there in Romania are you
familiar with the history of uh and this
goes deeper this you can do a whole
segment on but I'm just curious have you
heard of this uh Vlad Dracula
yes I was gonna not funny enough you I'm
so glad you asked it which is a guy who
used to spike Muslims I was actually
going to include that in my thread yeah
I have a threat in my mind
if if the Romanian Judiciary continues
to demonstrate unjust Injustice and it
seem more evidence of their behavior
that was actually going to be one of my
posts it was going to be within my
thread yeah this is deep this goes much
much deeper now like what you were
saying so all right uh so answering the
question now you know people wondering
and I guess we went through all of this
and again Islam is clear Islam
eradicates all of this webcam porn you
know it's a you know porn industry and
this webcam all this account for more
than the Hollywood Industries
all of this all of this Islam has the
solutions as the antidote to all of this
and now somebody could have been doing
things from the past way way back then
they come into Islam they got a clear
slate now it doesn't mean that if
somebody does some wrong they don't are
not held to account absolutely you know
if they've done something but you've
uncovered cert you you are uncovering
certain things is now you've turned into
almost like an investigative journalist
and you're looking at the facts and
you're
exploring this uh deeper so to answer
the question for that people are asking
why is the Muslim the defending Andrew
Tate why is the Muslim going this far uh
pretty much in a nutshell how would you
answer this
um because it's my Islamic a moral duty
to seek Justice based on what the Quran
has taught us it's in Surah Nisa which
is aptly named the women and it's our
duty and it's not just in that just as
you mentioned more than 20 times in
Quran
um so for us that's our duty our duty is
to Allah and is to speak the truth and
if the truth is even against us and if
the truth is against the Judiciary or
even if the truths again take we will
speak out against it
and if there was a clear Lucid evidence
on the contrary you could you'd be you
would change your position in a
heartbeat okay
all right thank you very much may uh
Allah God Almighty rewards you uh thanks
for spending some time with us and
sharing some of these things you've
uncovered thanks for having me I do
appreciate it you're welcome
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum